we are opposing this legislation for a
variety of reasons the strongest being
concern for the safety of the students
it's very easy to say I'm on the side of
the kids my child could have a deadly
seizure tomorrow in politics everybody
says they're on the side of the kids but
who really is it was an ordinary morning
except that morning today on his
principal called and said they had to
call 911 because she had a seizure it
can be a life or death situation for
Gianna Gianna D Lorenzo survived that
day but her father Pat worries about
next time he have humor is located in
her brain which are causing uncontrolled
epilepsy seizures we have this beautiful
high functioning doctor something go
wrong
most seizures stop on their own but
Gianna is one of about 10,000 California
school kids who suffers from the type of
prolonged seizures that without a quick
response can result in brain damage or
death if your body doesn't trigger the
brain to shut off that seizure you have
to do something to interrupt it - that
is the drug designed for that purpose
the delivery system was designed to be
used by non medical professionals
because it's a syringe that is already
pre filled to the exact dose it's
approved by the FDA for laypeople to use
dr. Howard terrorist is a professor of
pediatrics at UC San Diego and a medical
consultant to school districts in
California it is a safe medication safe
and fast-acting says Terrace
it works so fast because it's
administered rectally rectally the drug
is absorbed very quickly you can't wait
five seven eight minutes for paramedics
to show up and ambulances usually don't
carry dire stats as terrorists
ambulances will have to pick that child
up take that child to the hospital that
child will have to be then assessed
quickly at the hospital and only then
will that child be able to get there die
estat a new California bill would allow
children to receive daya stat let's go
ahead to start with SB ten to
two one the bill sponsor State Senator
Bob Huff this bill will help ensure the
safety of the countless children
throughout California who live with
epilepsy and give their parents peace of
mind
dr. Terrace urged lawmakers to pass the
bill the Dyess that decision is not one
of those difficult decisions it is a
no-brainer decision the bill would allow
teachers and other non medical school
employees to administer the drug if they
volunteered and received training the
bill enjoys the support of groups like
the Epilepsy Foundation the California
Medical Association and the association
of California neurologists we urge you
to vote no I strongly opposes Phil but
not everyone supports the bill the
California school nurses organization
the California School Employees
Association one after another the
California Labor Federation California
Nurses Association union leaders urged
lawmakers to vote no California Teachers
Association the California Federation of
Teachers Union of healthcare
professionals in opposition why the
opposition opposing this legislation for
a variety of reasons the strongest being
concerned for the safety of the students
this is a very dangerous medication what
if it's a female student that is
injected in a very delicate part of the
body there is no distance far distance
between the vaginal cavity and the
rectum cavity they're worried about
child molestation cases hello you're
saving my child our unions are not on
the side of the children in this it's
exactly the opposite we care deeply for
children and we want them to receive the
most appropriate care and that means
they need a licensed medical person
caring for them the misconception about
daya stat is that it's such a safe drug
that anybody can give it gail mclean is
the southern section president of the
california school nurses organization
well some of the problems with daya stat
is that can lower their respiratory rate
it can affect somebody's breathing
afterwards might cause shallow breathing
they say when my daughter is already not
been breathing for a minute and a half
to two minutes that shallow breathing
far beats the other option of not
breathing but we don't have to speculate
about what might happen if nan nurses
were allowed to give daya stat because
that's what did happen in California for
about ten years until the California
nurses board changed the policy in
September 2009 we have had in the past
non nurses administer daya stat and
there have been some cases of bad
outcomes many of the stories that people
say when investigated may not even hold
water one case that I've heard about was
a student in that received three doses
before calling 9-1-1 and the student is
was intubated on earth a respirator
afterwards how do we know that that
respiratory depression wasn't part of
the seizure seizures also cause
respiratory depression it is so much
safer to try to do it than not to do it
dr. Terrace testified that the
experience had been very safe we have
had no problems it has begun very well
no child has been harmed as a result
with his experience and opinion I
appreciate that but in but I don't
believe it's safe across the state in
every situation in every case Sacramento
lawmakers agreed and the bill died in
committee without ever being voted on
don't say this is about safety it is not
this is purely the pressure from the
unions because they see it as a jobs
bill I see it as a children's safety
bill the ulterior motive here isn't
protecting their kids it's getting more
nurses to say that nurses associations
are putting their interest in front of
children could not be further from the
truth indeed we have more concern and
safety issues for children and that's
why we want to see daya stat given by a
licensed professional nurse but dr.
Terris likens the diastatic controversy
to CPR Society would not be better off
if only nurses and doctors were allowed
to administer CPR laypeople could
certainly make mistakes but we don't ban
them from performing this potentially
life-saving procedure giving dies that
is safer than administering CPR so we
should allow laypeople to learn how to
do this my feeling is that many
physicians and physicians groups do not
understand how schools operate I don't
think they appreciate how our our school
systems are set up and and all the
responsibilities that we have today it's
hard for parents to know if schools will
give their children die stadt when they
need it dr. Tara says some children will
get it
others will have to wait till they get
to the hospital we think the solution
the school districts need to hire
appropriate staff to care for our
children when I see that people are
using children with seizures as a lever
to get more school nurses I think it's
wrong we say to parents who disagree
with this with this solution join us in
demanding for quality medical care for
their child while they're at school
maybe nurses great government schools
find a way we don't risk my child's life
until that day comes